it all notes let's talk about that a
little bit that's an insider when you
say the motivations what do you mean
well let me give you an example of sort
of disruption that gets ugly one
investment that that I was looking at
when I was at Warriors capital as part
of a health care forum was a the first
indigenous syringe manufacturing company
in East Africa in Kenya now you have
something very strange going on in East
in East Africa something very strange is
happening where you have demand for
approximately 800 million syringes in
the whole of East Africa if you imagine
what's going on there particularly at
the moment and you have supply of about
400 million and they're being imported
mostly from Asia they're being imported
at about two dollars a syringe and
they're being sold in some cases all the
way up to sixteen dollars a syringe
someone somewhere is making a lot of
money and I think we can all guess who
you know these are these are people in
government and so on and so forth but
the ugly side of it is that the
international institutions sometimes the
the NGOs and and other actors even
philanthropic actors foundations are
helping to perpetuate this market
failure and market distortion and and
being Frank with everyone in the room I
think one of the unfortunate everyone in
the publix in the positive airway
apologizes I think one of the one of the
unfortunate conclusions that we came to
is that particularly in the case of some
of these more sensitive sectors like
health care and often less if you like
impactful ones often telecoms is a good
example in some cases financial services
and I wonder having had this experience
the extent to which some of these
sexually orientated funds how far they
can go because when you start to tread
on those entrants public sector
interests you suddenly find that the
company that you were going to invest in
didn't get the import permits that it
was looking for or isn't able to import
the plastic resin that then makes the
syringes that's going to undercut that
whole market so it becomes very very
much disruption is murky and and just to
flesh that because they are players who
are making a profit perhaps internally
yeah so they for people who are
pocketing that spread between the two
dollar import price
and the $16 sale price they have an
interest in keeping the market exactly
as it is absolutely no